auch in der woche der beisetzung von
george floyd streiten die vereinigten
staaten von amerika weiter über
rassismus und über polizeigewalt
was ist donald trumps beitrag zu dieser
diskussion
er hat den zaun ums weiße haus noch mal
ein bisschen höher machen lassen
ja muss wahrscheinlich wieder mexiko
bezahlen außerdem wird schon ab nächster
woche große indoor
wahlkampfveranstaltung abhanden ist ein
wahnsinn ideale corona bedingungen aber
man kann ja vorher desinfektionsmittel
trinken und dann hat er bei dieser
veranstaltung garantiert wieder auf
deutschland rum
warum weil wir zu wenig für rüstung
bezahlen
[Applaus]
grob übersetzt merkel muss ist
stinksauer auf angela weil angela seinen
g 7 gipfel hat platzen lassen
aber das seid ihr jetzt schönheim du bis
zu 9500 der derzeit 35.000 in
deutschland stationierten soldaten
abziehen
zwei im sinn das ist ein drittel wenn es
wirklich dazu kommt dass wir voll
ungünstig dann müssen wir uns hier quasi
ich kann das kaum aussprechen selber
verteidigen
[Musik]
hol dir jetzt call auf deutschland das
strategiespiel mit maximalem
schwierigkeitsgrad verteidige die
bundesrepublik aber jetzt kommt nachdem
die us truppen abgezogen sind
kein einziger panzer fährt nicht schnell
repariert hielt danach den kaputten
hubschrauber den kaputten eurofighter
das kaputte g36 und das bonanza rad der
verteidigungsministerin und dann geht
auch noch der schraubenschlüssel kaputt
misst das war der letzte ball auf
deutschland so realistisch dass es
absolut keinen spaß macht
mal gucken ob der tramp das wirklich
durchzieht am ende und es ist komisch
ich bin ja auch geprägt von der
friedensbewegung der 80er das heißt ich
müsste jetzt total erleichtert sein
über den angedachten truppenabzug warum
fühle ich das nicht was stimmt nicht mit
mir
ich leite die frage mal direkt weiter an
unsere heute schulbetriebs psychologin
wirtes schneider ja was stimmt sie mit
ihnen herr welke wo fängt man an
damit beschäftigt sich ein ganzer
forschungszweig aber wenn wir jetzt mal
nur bei ihrer ami psychose bleiben dann
ist es ganz einfach ein teil von ihnen
denkt immer noch ami go home
der andere teil will beschützt und
dominiert werden im grunde das alte
spiel von unterwerfung und schmerz und
klassische sexting ich bin pervers
verkürzt gesagt ja vor allem aber
braucht ihre deutsche psyche den bösen
ami um sich moralisch überlegen zu
fühlen
das schützt vor zu viel selbstkritik
trump doof böse da müssen wir gar nicht
darüber nachdenken was wir selber zur
zerrüttung beigetragen haben
achten sie mal hier auf das gesicht von
merkel als tramp sagt er kommt bald nach
deutschland und er ist stolz auf sein
deutsches blut noch zwei drei solche
gesichtsausdrücke und wir können unsere
bunker in der normandie wieder
renovieren
deutschland braucht den ami als negative
kontrast fläche total schlimm der
rassismus bei der us-polizei stimmt
diese form von polizeigewalt haben wir
hier nicht aber wenn saskia esken auch
nur fragt ob es möglicherweise latenten
rassismus bei unseren sicherheitskräften
gibt schreien alle buch generalverdacht
wer ist das
der punkt natürlich steht die große
mehrheit bei der polizei auf dem boden
der verfassung trotzdem berichten ja
immer wieder mitbürger die nicht deutsch
genug aussehen dass sie regelmäßig
zufällig kontrolliert werden hier dieser
mann mit einem schwank aus seiner
schulzeit er kommt von der nachhilfe und
und wurde dann auf gehalten von
zivilpolizisten und wurde kontrolliert
nach waffen und drogen meine ganzen
nachbarn laufen an mir vorbei und
schauen und die denken auch nicht also
sowohl davon allem dem was ich erlebt
habe so denken die auch nicht ob meine
arme david sondern die denken alle
chancen
was hat er gemacht habe gesteht mützen
über ein drittel der menschen mit
migrationshintergrund berichtet von
diskriminierung bei der wohnungssuche
und trotzdem ist hier jede debatte über
systemischen rassismus offensichtlich
ein afro weil der ami der sehr viel
schlimmer
ja stimmt ja auch diese unverschämten
usa bestehen darauf dass wir deutschen
zwei prozent unseres
bruttoinlandsprodukts für rüstung
ausgeben das wären im letzten jahr fast
70 milliarden gegenfrage warum hat
deutschland das mit den zwei prozent
2014 bei der nato unterschrieben war mir
da besoffen bei den amis regen uns auf
wenn sie vereinbarungen mit füßen treten
aber hier sagen wir kinder ist doch bloß
nur unterschrift schild male und sie
bitte auf ich will mich wieder überlegen
fühlen
seit dem wahlsieg von donald trump
wissen wir
europa muss sich um seinen eigenen
schutz kümmern bei dem vogel ist es
möglich dass er nächste woche aus der
nato austritt weil keine ahnung weil
seine bräunungscreme alle ist trotzdem
verlässt sich europa weiter auf die amis
und weil zur therapie auch härte gehört
sage ich ihnen jetzt mal was wir werden
uns nie mehr beschützen und selber
können wir es nicht scheiße was mache
ich denn jetzt ganz einfach sie brauchen
einen neuen sugardaddy der sie beschützt
und dominiert aber keine angst da steht
schon einer in den startlöchern
jetzt habe ich angst und bin geil ich
weiß würde schneider
ich wollte euch nur um ein kleines auto
bieten
einfach anklicken macht's gut
los los du scheiße fährt